I want to watch the movie so what's the
question now we have the thing called on
helpful advice okay do you know what it
is no people have emails and they have
and then they have a quote you'll just
fit and you can answer them or you don't
have to have oh yeah okay I love it
unhelpful vice with Bobby
kalila at Dillard Francis High Tiger
belly and wait what the [ __ ] was that
use that real a second city in Chicago
Rome okay did you just do wait oh my god
you put a voice effect on no no no yeah
yeah oh my god [ __ ] yeah that's
incredible
oh no no that is Nate Dogg blowing my
mind right now we'll remove what movie
boo I can't wait to see the movie with
that boy I'm in the cell right now
you're the self yeah goddamn broke scoot
scoot scoot scoot
let's get school hi tiger belly I'm
going through some really bad heartache
right now they are they're all like this
we said we skipped three weeks of
relationship so this is the first one in
a while I'm so down for this my
girlfriend and I did it for the past
year she's cheating on you actually we
broke up at 364 days and spent our
one-year anniversary as a one long
beautiful epic date we spent the entire
day crying laughing occasionally
distracting ourselves and crying some
more we were long distance in our past
led in very different directions we were
madly in love and we still are but it
was just too hard on the both of us
it was the healthiest breakup both of us
ever have ever gone through if when
sickroom stances are better we would
like to give it another shot
but oh my god I feel like I'm [ __ ]
dying sorry for the ramp and I was
wondering what is the worst breakup you
have ever experienced when does it get
better
does it ever truly get better I mean
holy dude we already already hit this in
the beginning just go back to my willow
story can you replay that in the video
how old is have you
the most painful heart and heartbreak
for you no no for us a background I'm 26
am I'm fruit yeah I way sex yeah he's 26
she's 24 neither of us have ever been in
healthy relationships before we met each
other what was your most painful was it
but mine isn't about feet you sniff oh
Tara block every woman that I've been
heartbroken over were women I weren't
with you yeah they were women that I
obsessed about it was unrequited love
and many its instances they never even
knew about my attraction to them it was
just friendzone like from the beginning
and I would stay in these things
laughing I'm sorry
at the person's email cuz very heart
phone I forgot that it's a real person
emailing that
yeah and it's sorry laughing at 9 and
I'll try to contain my when I went to
when I went to rehab I went to rehab
with this girl named Tara black she
lived in Encinitas and she I used to
sleep over at her house as friends and
once you'd be asleep I used to stare at
her toes for for like five hours
straight
five hours Judas little things I've ever
[ __ ] seen and I you know what I used
to get on my hands and knees and pray
dear God please I'll kill or I'll do
anything for this woman and then she
would go hi okay well you wanna go let's
go to beach I know just watch her go in
the water or her toes in her toes
okay now I'm remembering the one true
love that not the one she loved because
that's the one obsession you want that
the one that really got me yeah I I
she lived up in Northridge and if you're
listening to this yeah [ __ ] you man
Northridge yeah and I would text her all
the time I'd go and hang out with her I
would swim in her pool I was I want to
say I was like okay so you know you
weren't a DJ no no you were just a
regular sort of regular boy yeah yeah
yeah yeah
so Northridge Northridge this is was
when aim existed I think and we'd aim
all the time talk so much call on the
phone and I remember just like tried to
keep getting closer try it she just
wouldn't have it wouldn't have it and
like there was certain points where I
was like I think up didn't happen didn't
happen and then one time her her friend
called me and her friend was the one I
had to break the news to me be like
she's not she's not into you she want to
hang out anymore
and then the later on I found out that
her for the reason she was hanging out
with me was so much because she was
trying to pawn me off the on the to the
friend that was the one that broke the
news to me and I was so heartbroken dude
I was crying up in my room for how long
for you know weeks on end I love that
story
it was so sad love I love that you had
to suffer I had I had to take the bus
cuz my mom I would go to school in the
valley my mom wouldn't take me on the
weekends of the valley cuz she's like I
Drive you five days a week I'm not gonna
take you for these extra two days so I
had to take the [ __ ] bus the 7:25
from from Westwood all the way to them
to Van Nuys and then figure out how to
get to Northridge and did that that
young larvae young heartbreaking that
that's right that thing is that is I
haven't felt that in 25 years when I
hear the Brian McKnight song did do I
ever cross your mind anytime
I still cry really think about like oh
yeah same thing when I was 16 I fell in
love with a older guy that went to
Harvard but he was like rich drove an
Audi and I went to like Blair high
school I had a really skinny eyebrows a
little for chili yeah but he like took
interest in me
and I remember giving him one of my mall
photos you know the ones they're so
amazing a dumb room you know like and oh
I never really like got him it and I I
swear god there's a few and stained
there's another stain song but I just to
this day like I get like shivers down my
spine
I just dream of toes these little toes
those little toes tarah toes there's
another one have you seen her like what
I don't know I don't know what she looks
like anymore I don't know what no I
don't care what about your girl what she
looks like yeah I mean I've seen what
she looks like now what did she look
like
nothing I'm interested in completely
yeah yeah completely like nothing I'm
interested in at all but you did like
Boyd went oh yeah I find out yeah ask
you this
we've single you're single now right
yeah if she wanted to get back would you
know why no honestly I've I'm just like
fully not interested in why though I
don't what if she's watching what if I
said she's got like plastic surgery on
her lips like her lips look like I'm
sorry I'm sorry it's not it's not you
know you know what it is watching this
right now my guys still super dreamy yes
unfortunately yeah yeah he's like the
king of Taiwan it's really unfortunate
he's the king of Taiwan there's this
other girl that that this is a good
story too I hadn't I hadn't done
anything yet
like I'd kissed you know maybe I had P P
touches over pants or something but uh
just there was this girl that was in the
grade above me and I was obsessed with
her I went to the school laksa and she
would drive we know he would take the
bus back to her place and I would just
hang out with her all the time she had a
boyfriend and I would just hang on a
pike waiting for her to just break up
with that dude just sitting there so
yeah and I was telling her how much I
was into her too I was like man when you
break up really it's it's amazing yeah
and she broke up with him and I drove
the bus back home and I was like oh my
god oh my god oh my god I've talked
about this moment all the time to her
like what do i do what do i do what i do
what i do and i IE that you know those
movie moments where you see the movie
you're like what are you doing yeah yeah
so i'm sitting in her bed and she gets
on top of me she pushes me down and she
starts making out with me and I'm like I
have I don't know what to do I don't
have to do I haven't touched a vagina
before I patted him I touch him when I
was in kindergarten we played doctor I
don't know what to do though I know
know what to do how old are you I think
I was like probably 17 you don't know
what to do
no I I was a late bloomer okay and so I
was like I pushed her off and I was like
I am I should go
I should go oh and I did that and I kept
looking back sup sup we might have to
shut it down no because that's the
dumbest thing ever but you hyped it up
in your head too much oh yeah no no I
know that's the dumbest [ __ ] thing
I've ever heard in my foot just tell you
that yeah I know that's don't worry I
never tell you that you just reignited
something in my heart right now okay
number one I'm not watching a movie with
you tonight
that's a week that's some weak [ __ ]
number two we might not air this podcast
number three Diplo season two not me are
you involved that's the dumbest [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] you with that why you got up ago I
don't know I don't know I freaked out I
put I made it too big in my head it was
it was honestly like a year of hanging
out with her and not God talking about
dropping the ball if you talk about this
that would be the worst movie ever made
if you saw that in the movie people
would walk out I want my money back
movies like I premise that literally I
don't care this is not fair you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] thank you anyway good
job good job
well I'm just trying to know what
happened after that i jizz my pants dude
oh you did I did you did you ever have a
second shot at it
no never I tried to hang out with her
again and then she just didn't want to
she didn't want to have anything to do
with me well that was probably like a
pity [ __ ] anyways on her and yeah I was
trying to get it I tried to get that
later on I just didn't want to embarrass
myself I was like cuz she had done
everything the [ __ ] all over her face
all the time home and I'm just like a
little prude boy like
let me ask you this had you [ __ ]
before yes
okay 17 I'm yet alright so you know how
all works yeah for himself but you know
about direction no not at that time no
no you don't know how to do aviation yet
school did you ever license now I can
find no ok we could you walk no you
don't know ok I'm just gonna keep
getting reamed on this one you know I'm
not done okay so you know about [ __ ]
I just wanna know why did you do what
did i do no because you said you don't
know about juicing on P faces I'm was
gonna tell you I'll tell you why it
pisses him off because he was never
offered that when he was 17 uh-huh had
he been offered he would have been game
and done it but he was never offered cuz
girls didn't like him and here you are
wasting a good opportunity oh that's
funny white privilege you laughing cuz
you just see that was a white privilege
problem it wasn't two white people white
out my bad my bad
well how old were you then when you lost
your virginity eighteen okay so the year
after you just weren't ready at 7:00 no
no I was not ready I was not and I and I
did everything with one girl every
single thing that I did was with her
first time you did it did you think you
had good form I still don't have good
form but can I just say this I'm gonna
get my nut off that's that I'm not gonna
if it listen once I'm invited in which
is the kissing part yeah at that point
I'm gonna finish the journey what you
did was this is what you did okay
Frodo no pit no Dino Rance came off no
answer oh no got the ring
no you never had never Shire I never got
the ring you never left the Shire
and then Saruman has the ring the movies
ten minutes long and the whole world is
[ __ ] burned down to the ground
nobody's because you don't know how to
we just were kissing and then I pushed
her off that's what I'm saying that's
getting the ring but at least I didn't
you get pillows at least I didn't like
try to put the ring on and like dribble
a little bit I didn't disappear I didn't
get to disappear okay listen I'm gonna
apologize for what I said it's okay man
no no I'm gonna read I might not watch
the movie with you tonight but I might
not do Diplo maybe if they offer no
scenes I'm not gonna say I'm gonna have
no scenes with him okay and your writer
and this is definitely not getting air
I'm kidding all those three are not true
okay and I forgive you back to this guy
I have no idea what the [ __ ] I'll see ya
that question was really really weird
weird because because one thing it
didn't when does it get better what the
[ __ ] are you talking about what do you
like what do you know what do you want
to do do you want to be with her or not
that's the thing you got to [ __ ]
figure out what does that mean you guys
have a long distance relationship cut it
off and go get better yeah yeah that's
my I mean for me you got to you nailed
it right there for me you know you you
see the planet right you know how many
people are on the planet and to me it's
like you know I read something on a that
said this before on a podcast before on
this podcast before but a statistic that
said that you're compatible with one out
of every 33 million people or some 33
know you've really said this does
[ __ ] III honestly think you could be
compatible with these one added like 20
what do you people yeah that's a lot
there are so many different ways you can
take your life I feel like there is it
33 you're compatible 1 over 33 million
you said yeah you could date you could
date 3 3 million people and those 33
million will be compatible with you oh
it's what I meant that's not 1 in 33
million men that's 33 out of 33 million
sorry you could be compatible with 33
million people okay
if what I'm saying it's not a lot of
people you already told us before that
that statistics in line lied to us you
told us I just see all of you I just see
the hope you point it to all trying to
make this person feel good
I lied again and what let me see
something right now I lie all the time
I'm The Lion King the Lion King I'm the
shadow king soul mate so you think a
person can have what's there is no such
thing as you don't say you're soul mates
wait look can we go to the next question
yeah thanks because when soul mates come
out I'm out do you believe in soul mates
I don't know yet yeah me neither
I think you're my soul mate baby I think
that we you're my person like we can
live this long life together no we
cannot sit I don't know if you're the
only one I could live this long life no
you're not the only one either
exactly I so at this point it's a choice
right I really like you I like you too
yeah different questions
[Music]